hey everyone bandit here of all the fan
bases in the wide wide world of video
games the zelda fan base tends to stand
out for several reasons one of which is
the tendency for zelda fans to wonder
about what's not shown to them in the
video games this activity is also known
as theorizing for instance take link the
hero the the guy my dude sometimes he's
got a grandma sometimes he's got an
uncle sometimes a little sister but
where are his parents huh where are they
nintendo why is hyrule always changing
why is there only one breed of dog in
breath of the wild why are there no
female gorons choose one of these
questions mix in a couple of repeated
symbols across the fan base sprinkle in
some similar color schemes and garnish
it with a nice little touch of what they
said in the original japanese version of
the game and that's theorizing in a
nutshell
but to be honest with you it is a lot of
fun which is why i love doing it a lot
probably too much but anyway i know good
and well that the zelda youtube people
who are on the screen are not the only
types of fans that theorize about the
legend of zelda we all do on the screen
off the screen whatever which is why i
asked you about this the other day in
one of my community posts so i thought
it would be cool to talk about some of
your theories for a change to hear from
some of the zelda fanbase that isn't on
the screen and i picked five of the most
interesting in my opinion of course
theories from the comments section of
that one community post and we're gonna
be talking about them in this video last
little disclaimer here is please
remember that there are definitely some
like duplicates of theories in the
comments of that community post but i
will be crediting only the first
commenter that i saw to post said theory
oh and be sure to leave a like on this
video in support of us the fan base that
theorizes alright number one more people
reincarnate in hyrule than simply link
zelda and ganondorf this is a very
interesting theory because like lots of
things in the zelda universe it's just
kind of there and isn't really explained
people like impa who appears six
different times across eight different
zelda games or beetle who appears five
different times across six different
games are examples of this fact while
we're not presently able to answer this
mystery with any sort of confidence we
can definitely speculate and create our
own head canon which can be just as fun
in my opinion since beetle and impa
always come back as pretty much the same
individual and since we know that ghosts
and spirits exist in the land of hyrule
and of course since we already know that
the spirit of the hero reincarnates as
also pretty much the same individual
each time but without any memories of
his past lives i just assume that people
like beetle and impa kind of work the
same way whether orchestrated by the
goddesses or some other power what if
there was a spirit of the merchant or a
spirit of the defender who are the
spirits responsible for incarnating time
and time again as beetle and impa we may
never know the concrete answer to this
mystery for sure but until then this is
what i'm going with number two the
zora's evolution into the rito race was
not natural it was a product of divine
intervention okay so you know how the
rito who first appeared in the game wind
waker as the race of bird people who
live on dragon roost island evolved from
the zora who don't make a living
appearance in the game well after the
gods flooded the world with water to try
to stop ganon you know filling the world
with more water and less land have you
ever stopped to think about why that
would have forced fish people to evolve
into bird people if anything it may have
forced birds to evolve back into fish
since there was so much more water
everywhere and less land and trees for
birds to perch on however this theory
insinuates that because the gods flooded
hyrule to bury it beneath the sea along
with ganon and his monsters what if the
gods also forced the zora to evolve into
the rito so that the land underneath the
waves would remain untouched pretty
interesting isn't it also wouldn't that
kind of make hyrule atlantis
anyway moving on number three zelda has
to die to truly end the curse of the
demon tribe for those of you who are
familiar with the story of skyward sword
you know all too well that at the end of
the game demise aka the og demon king
can be seen cursing the descendants of
hylia aka all future zeldas and the
spirit of the hero aka all future links
with being visited by an incarnation of
demise's hatred for the rest of eternity
pretty harsh stuff i know but no matter
how you slice it according to demise's
own words zelda and link are the two
individuals who are cursed right quote
those like you those who share the blood
of the goddess and the spirit of the
hero they are eternally bound to this
curse right if you want to get technical
even the original japanese text
specifically states that quote you
people who possess the blood of the
goddess and the soul of the hero shall
forever be unable to escape from this
curse you people here you know what let
me write this in equation form i'm sorry
if this turns out looking horrible if
link plus zelda equals bad stuff then no
link and no zelda equals no bad stuff
makes sense right and sure demise
ultimately wants the triforce but he
didn't curse the triforce he cursed its
protectors link and zelda number four
are heart pieces or heart containers
considered canon this is kind of a funny
one because it's clearly meant to be a
piece of progressive gameplay i mean
obviously but it's a mystery that you
can't exactly dismiss either because
doing so would require you to dismiss
conversations and even entire characters
as non-canon from within the zelda games
like poking holes in the games like
swiss cheese
take the skull kids in the lost woods of
ocarina of time for instance after link
plays their songs back to them they
reward him with a piece of heart if
pieces of heart aren't canon and
therefore don't actually exist in zelda
lore then what else would they have
given him that we didn't get to see or
did this encounter even really happen in
the first place you would think it did
happen though since the skull kid from
majora's mask seems to remember link the
same question can be raised for the
pieces of heart rewarded from the
fishing hole or from the bomb chew
bowling alley or for bringing mama yu
yan her little puppy back do these
people or these encounters not actually
exist either and this debate is true for
all zelda games since pieces of heart
are kind of a staple of the series if
they aren't canon then i guess we just
need to get used to seeing stuff that
simply isn't real in these games but if
they are canon then that sparks an
entire other discussion about how link's
life works and why other people would
even have these things in the first
place but alas those are theories for
another day lastly does the mummified
ganondorf from the breath of the wild 2
trailer prove that breath of the wild
takes place in the fallen timeline and i
know that i said i took 5 theory ideas
from the comment section but
actually i only took four this one is
submitted by yours truly the gist of it
is that we know ganondorf was killed and
turned to stone in the adult timeline
right and in the child timeline was
stabbed through and completely killed as
well even though we don't actually know
what happened with old ganondorf's body
after twilight princess the fact remains
that he did actually die in that
timeline by way of a wound that should
permanently be visible on his body the
fallen timeline is the only one that
doesn't account for his physical body
only that he turned into the demon ganon
at some point prior to the events of a
link to the past if you look at the
ganondorf corpse in the breath of the
wild two trailers he definitely doesn't
look like he's made of stone and while
lots of people claim that the place the
green hand was holding him in the middle
of his chest is the same spot that he
was stabbed in in twilight princess ever
since we got the new trailer that shows
him standing up facing the camera if you
look at his chest there's no stab wound
where there should be one if this really
is the ganondorf from twilight princess
the only possibility left would be the
fallen timeline ganondorf whose body we
don't actually know what happened to
right and it is also true that according
to creating a champion the hylians don't
record the events of wind waker or
twilight princess as part of their
history they only record that ganondorf
became ganon and then reincarnated over
and over again this fits perfectly
within and only within the fallen
timeline where ganon was resurrected at
least four times with the fifth being
prevented as a result of the adventure
of link but of course since there are
many other factors in breath of the wild
that have made its timeline placement
notoriously debatable this remains just
my theory and that's the video did you
guys like these theories your theories
or did you think that they were way off
also would you like to see more videos
done in this format kind of as a give
and take from the community let me know
what you think in the comments below
also be sure to like this video if you
liked this video to get it spread around
to other zelda fans just like you and me
and subscribe to the channel if you
haven't already for much more nintendo
content to come as always humongous
thanks goes out to my bandit crew who
are the reason i'm able to do this kind
of content in the first place please say
hello to love hugh marcelo c brian t and
puzzle girl who all decided generously
to join the ranks of my elite if you
watching are interested in getting your
name up here with my crew and helping
these videos come to life please feel
free to check out that join button
located below any of my videos or follow
the links in the description to my
patreon and merge pages also down there
are the links to my social media pages
so come follow me on twitter or
instagram for all sorts of cool little
nuggets of whatever the heck i'm
thinking that's all i've got in this one
so as always i hope you have a wonderful
rest of your day this is bandit looking
forward to seeing you in the next one
and signing out
[Music]
you